l'agriculture française et les
agriculteurs français ont subi un
événement climatique extraordinaire et
sans précédent à bien des égards
extraordinaire par l'ampleur des
températures négatives qui ont été
présents dans chacun des territoires et
son précédent dans l'ampleur puisque
l'ensemble dès territoires où quasiment
l'ensemble des territoires français ont
été touchés avec des pans entiers de
notre agriculture qui ont été touchés je
pense à l'arboriculture je pense à la
viticulture je pense aussi aux grandes
cultures pour un certain nombre de
productions
il n'est pas nouveau malheureusement
pour le monde agricole de devoir faire
face aux éléments parce qu'au fond c'est
un métier qui en permanence
malgré son travail mais là c'est fort et
soumis ici à la grêle la la sécheresse
la des inondations et aujourd'hui à des
événements comme ceux qu'on a connus au
travers du gel évidemment les messages
de soutiens divers que nous leur
apportons sont précieux mais au-delà de
ça il ya la responsabilité des uns et
des autres en particulier du
gouvernement avec deux volets un volet
de court terme évidemment qu'il a mise
en oeuvre des dispositifs que nous
connaissons les calamités agricoles
les fonds de soutien éventuellement les
systèmes assurantiels qu'il faut activer
dans le plus rapidement possible parce
qu'au fond c'est des revenus qui vont
disparaître
mécaniquement par l'épisode de jeunes
que nous connaissons et c'est ce à quoi
il faut qu'on fasse face dans l'urgence
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait le
ministre julien de normandie avec le
premier ministre en se rendant très tôt
très vite sur place pour annoncer un
certain nombre de mesures d'urgence à
l'endroit des agriculteurs concernés et
ils sont très nombreux
et puis il faut qu'on ait une réflexion
plus globale parce qu'on voit bien que
le dérèglement climatique est à l'oeuvre
et qu'au fond en parfois moins de huit
jours parfois même moins de cinq jours
on a vu des amplitudes thermiques de
plus de 20 voire de 25° passant de ce
qui était un temps estival à un temps
qui était plutôt un temps hivernal et
donc il faut qu'on travaille sur un
système assurantiel qui soit organisé
sur d'autres bases au niveau national et
sans doute au niveau européen pour faire
face à ces aléas climatiques qui sont
des aléas de production et qui sont
parfois des aléas de production majeure
et puis aussi que nous travaillons avec
les agriculteurs avec tous ceux qui sont
touchés sur quels sont les systèmes
techniques qui permettraient de mieux
faire face à ce type d'aléas mais en
tout cas c'est ça le choix qu'il faut
qu'on ait une réponse de court terme une
réponse de solidarité une réponse
immédiate pour faire face à l'urgence
c'est à dire la trésorerie qui va
manquer les revenus qui vont manquer la
production qui va disparaître cette
année
pour un certain nombre de secteurs et
puis au moyen et long terme de regarder
des systèmes qui leur permette au fonds
de continuer à exercer leur activité
avec une forme de sérénité si tant est
qu'on puisse en avoir dans un métier qui
est très dépendant des aléas
météorologiques une forme de sérénité
plus grande autour de système
assurantiel qui leur permettent de
passer des écueils comme ce que nous
sommes en train de traverser